[Applause]  and steph curry is laying down  not sure if he got hurt as they were  diving for loose balls  you see curry  wincing right now  and that foul is on draymond green he  has fouled out with 407 remaining much  to the delight of this crowd  green's got to be careful he's giving  courtney cookland  portland an earful  the warriors need all five guys in there  they're small they're unathletic  and it looked like steph curry got hurt  as al hoffman  gold for the loose ball landed on his  leg  curry  is limping right now he's upset  and left leg that he lands on as he dies  for the loose ball to me that's not  dirty that's just good hustle from  everybody unfortunately curry winds up  getting his leg landed on